the Democrat parade of idiocy last night
was so spectacular we felt compelled to
bring back the Ingram Awards okay
joining me to present these prestigious
awards and comment as Pradesh lap senior
advisor to the Trump 2020 campaign she's
live from CPAC West in Reno Nevada also
here is Tom Bevin co-founder and
executive director of Real Clear
Politics alright guys great to see you
on a Friday night first up
okay we're calling this the Annie grab
your gun award and it goes to beta
O'Rourke well apparently he can't stand
a man with a gun are you proposing
taking away their guns and how would
this work I am if it's a weapon that was
designed to kill people
hell yes we're gonna take your ar-15
your ak-47 Mercedes bado
leaned into this stereotype in veiling
the new slogan bado has a band for that
he actually unveiled that is this going
to win well definitely won't win states
like Texas for example and even today
speaking to several of the audience
members in Nevada that you know they had
a very serious discussion on the Second
Amendment and the fact that in
especially in the rural counties of
Nevada and certain states like New
Mexico that they're very concerned about
their second Amendment rights being
violated again we you know there is
there is this a need to figure out how
we deal with gun violence absolutely and
the president has addressed this issue
when it comes to figuring out how we
deal with more extensive background
checks it's different when you're
talking about taking away guns from
law-abiding citizens it absolutely
violates our Second Amendment rights and
it's it's incredibly troubling and while
the base the liberal base gets very
excited about this and Vado's obviously
trying to gain some points on the
liberal side I think when you look at
common sense Americans are saying wait a
second he's going way too far
no and Tom just really quickly on this
I'm gonna get to the next award last
year I think or the year before last he
an interview radio interview it or he
basically contradicted everything he's
saying now so I guess we can say in
Liberal land he's evolved on this issue
but what a wild message for someone from
Texas all the stuff on the internet was
today was you just try come and try and
try and come and take my ar-15 people
we're not having any of this yeah and
look there's been a lot of talk about
bado who's probably not gonna win the
Democratic nomination but going back and
challenging John Cornyn for Texas if
Republicans were had the slightest worry
about bado running for Senate in Texas
they're not worried anymore he's he's
made himself unelectable in the state of
Texas all right next up for the awards
the best schooling of a Rhodes Scholar
Award goes to pullian Castro mayor Pete
was a little shell-shocked he reminds
everybody of what they cannot stand
about Washington scoring points against
each other kind of poking at each other
and telling each other that that you're
my plan your play look we all know
that's called a democratic primary
election
[Applause]
in election Mercedes mayor Pete looked
like he should have been filming like a
got milk ad or something he just soap
yeah he's like looks like you know
school boy look very young you guys are
being mean to each other and Castro's
like this is called politics I'm not a
big fan of Castro but that was a good
moment yeah I thought it was the
exchange was intense and you know for
Pete to get intense it doesn't happen
too often but he kind of mumbled his way
through and you know I think it's again
these second-tier candidates that are
really breaking through and and Pete
hasn't really offered a vision as none
of many of these Democrats they haven't
offered a vision of how they want to
move forward and help America grow
especially from the terms as you said
earlier from an economic standpoint so
you know I thought that the exchange it
was bizarre between the two of them and
you know Pete's trying to take the upper
hand on this but you know I think it
just fell flat yeah well and this is one
of my favorite Awards and it's a that's
that's a high bar all right Tom the most
likely to conduct the Boston
Philharmonic award goes to Bernie
Sanders all right Bernie Sanders look
like Leonard Bernstein up there watch we
are spending twice as much per capita on
health care as the Canadians or any
other major country on earth this
American
yeah but Americans don't want to pay
twice as much Tom he does like to do
this a lot and it's quite interesting
we're having fun with Bernie but did he
hit his peak in 2016 I mean he's been
replaced in the progressive Lane hasn't
he who's been edged out by absolutely
absolutely I mean Bernie he's this is
the sort of you know Bernie 2.0 it's
just the crankier louder version he
seems to be angry and shouting all the
time
and there are there are different models
now newer models fresher models more
exciting models but bernie is staying
true to himself for what it's worth but
it's to say it's the same story every
time he steps on that debate stage yeah
I mean Mercedes he does look kind of
angry all the time and people say
Trump's angry trucks actually in a
really good
I mean he fights back when he's hit but
Trump's actually having fun but he just
he's like that get off my lawn guy you
know the burnt Bernie and you know
President Trump has a great sense of
humor too so that's the best part one of
the best parts about him but I think for
Bernie his biggest challenge obviously
is that his policies really he has
defined that socialist branch of the
Democratic Party and and there's the
popularity that's growing around him and
Elizabeth Warren as we know they're
splitting that vote right now but
they've he's taken the party to such an
extreme and very much openly admitting
that he wants to raise taxes on the
middle class right but he's one of the
leads on this yeah but of the leaders on
pushing the middle class the band's
doubt the Tennyson as Tom said there are
new and improved models now all right we
got to get to the next one
for one of our most coveted Ingram
Awards it's the award for the best
Oprah giveaway moment
and the award goes to Andrew yang my
campaign will now give a freedom
dividend of $1,000 a month for an entire
year to ten American families someone
watching this at home right now well Tom
handouts are usually pretty popular with
the voters thank you one the drudge poll
so what about this one just is there
enough cash to buy the electorate yeah
this one obviously he's pushing the
universal basic income that's one of the
primary platinum planks of his platform
but I this got panned even by fellow
Democrats they all kind of even the ones
on the stage we're kind of giggling
laughing about it it didn't go over well
among even left-leaning folks on Twitter
so I think this was kind of a fail on
Andrew Yang's part he had touted this is
some big you know never before never
before seen thing that he was going to
do didn't really come off very well for
him I didn't think all right and one
more okay there's one more this is the
oh come on one more we have time the pot
kettle black award goes to beta O'Rourke
first beta made this slanderous claim
about President Trump a racism and
violence that have long been a part of
America was welcomed out into the open
and directed to my hometown of El Paso
Texas where 22 people were killed dozens
more grievously injured by a man
carrying a weapon he should never have
been able to buy in the first place
inspired to kill by our president
following that he also had the gall to
say this the bitterness the pettiness
the smallness of the moment the
incentives to attack one another and try
to make differences without distinctions
mountains out of mole hills we have to
be bigger
all right Mercedes real quick we have to
be bigger you know it's an outrage that
beta would attack the president and
actually blame the president for the
shooting this guy you know he's trying
to score political points it's he's
going nowhere no he's going nowhere
going nowhere should go to the School of
Rock open a franchise and call it a day
all right Mercedes Tom thanks so much